morning all boris johnson is well
unlikely to be waking up with a clear
head this morning with the continuing
ferrari over lockdown breaking parties
at number 10. the latest allegations
center on so-called wine time fridays
regular downing street drinking sessions
held throughout the pandemic the labour
leader secure stammer is renewing his
calls for the prime minister to resign
claiming that he's guilty of deceit and
deception our chief political
correspondent john craig reports
wine time fridays the latest allegation
of drinking inside 10 downing street
regularly witnessed during the pandemic
it's claimed by boris johnson
the daily mirror reports that the prime
minister encouraged staff to let off
steam despite lockdown rules and the
regular events were so popular that
staff bought a fridge to keep wine and
beer cool
downing street has not denied the latest
allegations which follow the pm being
forced to apologize to the queen over
parties on the eve of prince philip's
funeral when she was forced to mourn
alone
number 10 says the ongoing whitehall
investigation will look into the nature
of gatherings who attended where they
happened their purpose and whether they
obeyed the rules
but today sir starmer in a major speech
will turn up the heat on the pm on
downing street drinking after saying he
should be offering buckingham palace's
resignation as well as an apology
rather than concentrating on getting
through the pandemic and bringing down
waiting lists this self-indulgent tory
party is instead having a fight about a
leader who they should have known from
the start is not fit for office the
labour leader will say everybody now
sees the prime minister as a liar who
has tried to cheat his way out and break
the rules and has set the culture within
number 10 that has told other staff and
other people that they can carry on as
normal amid all the drinking allegations
some cabinet ministers are reported to
be claiming privately that the pm is in
the last chance saloon
the financial times quotes one long time
supporter lamenting he's done it's over
the prime minister we're told is
spending the weekend here in downing
street rather than going to checkers as
usual because a member of his family has
tested positive for covid
his mps meanwhile are mostly back in
their constituencies getting the verdict
of voters and disgruntled tory activists
on the latest lurid allegations of
partying here
despite professing her loyalty it's
claimed the foreign secretary liz truss
is wooing tory mps preparing for a
leadership bid
so too according to mps it's the
chancellor rishi sunak who
controversially visited devon on the day
of the pm's commons apology
in mr sunak's north yorkshire
constituency
voters back him to succeed mr johnson
yeah i'd like to see him gone and i see
rishi is the prime minister because i
think we can trust him
simply us i'm really disappointed in
everything that's come out and
i feel that everybody has really
worked hard to try and uphold all the
guidance
um and that we've been really let down
the prime minister meanwhile is plotting
a fight back including a clear-out of
officials tainted by the partying
scandal and axing plan b rules such as
covid passports masks and working from
home
he's calling his fight back operation
save big dog
he hopes it will bring his critics to
heal and save his premiership
john craig sky news
[Applause]
so could the party be over for boris
johnson see what i did there uh well
let's get the opinion of joe twyman he's
the director and co-founder of delta joe
really good to see you this morning um
look i i absolutely hate the phrase
cutting through you know the idea that
you people need to know about a story
for it to be a story but but what is the
evidence if there is indeed any evidence
that these allegations of parties are
are actually having an effect on the way
the public is viewing boris johnson in
his administration well in the world of
polling we tend to look at long-term
trends rather than short-term
fluctuations and the impact of these
latest stories has been that the
long-term trend the decline of the
conservative party in the increase of
the labour party lead that's accelerated
in light of these most recent
revelations and this is likely to be the
start of a difficult weekend for the
conservatives in terms of polling
results that are to be published in the
in the papers it's certainly not a good
situation at the moment and so in the
short term it's definitely cutting
through uh the conservatives are below
30 for the first time really since boris
johnson has become prime minister uh
labor have a double-digit lead and so
it's really a bad position for them
for the conservatives at the moment the
question is of course will this last
because it's all very well cutting
through and in the artificial
construction of a survey instrument
people saying oh well if there were a
general election tomorrow i would vote
labor but there isn't a general election
tomorrow and
the real question for all the parties is
where will they be not just next week
but next month and next year
and what this series of
stories has done to the conservatives is
firstly prevented them from moving on
and starting any kind of fight back but
also it appears to have led to a
cumulative narrative forming that many
people are starting to come on board
with and that is the idea
that the government doesn't play by its
own rules uh doesn't act fairly and in
many cases can't be trusted and that
rather than individual stories could be
a far more damaging thing to shake off
longer term
just
in terms of where perhaps boris johnson
is most feeling the pressure i mean look
one of the reasons why he has been so
impervious to criticism since 2000 uh
since of 2019 you know is the size of
the majority and a large chunk of that
majority came from seats which were not
necessarily conservative traditional
seats do we think that the effect has
been most felt amongst those perhaps
newer conservative voters or or is it in
in well in the heartland well in delta
paul's work at the end of the end of
last year we found the problem was more
acute in those
seats that the conservatives gained at
the last election than it was in those
seats that they held and many of those
seats will be of course traditional
labour heartlands the so-called red wall
and those are the seats that uh that
boys johnson won to give him this
majority and if he can't hold on to
those come the next election uh then it
will be very difficult for him to
achieve a majority and it's worth
pointing out of course that the labour
party don't need to win a majority of
the seats in order to get into
parliament the way that the uh the way
the electoral arithmetic is likely to
work means they just need to prevent the
conservatives getting a majority in
order to rule through some sort of
coalition and get the keys to downing
street
okay then joe simple question for you
who's going to be the next prime
minister then um if we just for a second
hypothesize that this might prove fatal
that the tories do get
the requisite number of letters to the
chairman of the 1922 committee if there
is a leadership contest who fills number
10 next well at the moment uh liz truss
is polling very well with conservative
members rishi sunak does very well with
the general public but neither of them
are actually particularly well known nor
have they been put up to the kind of
scrutiny that you would expect a a
conservative candidate to to be
subjected to so i imagine we're looking
at uh
we're looking at maybe one of those two
or perhaps uh perhaps someone who hasn't
been in the limelight so much perhaps
michael gove might be good for an
outside bet
um not so sure about that one just a
final point though joe just in terms of
um
an expectation that there might be an
election i mean do the british public
feel that things are starting to gather
ahead of steem i have to say i perhaps
don't
i don't think i don't think general
election is particularly likely because
because there doesn't need to be one uh
we've we've done away with the fixed
term parliament act and uh and there
doesn't need to be one for another
couple of years
and i imagine the conservatives now they
have the power to call that election
when they want to
we'll do it at the time that is best for
them so i can't see a general election a
leadership election even that i think is
is being over hyped at the moment i mean
understandably given all mps want to be
prime minister but
but i think we've got uh we've got
perhaps some way to go on that as well
yeah and some mps more than others uh
joe twyman really good to see you this
morning thanks being with us thanks
i mean well let's uh just reflect on the
latest daily cover data now it shows
almost a hundred thousand new cases of
coronavirus across the uk that's the
lowest for three months
another 270 deaths taking the number of
deaths within 28 days of a positive test
to 151
612.
and sky news has launched a new nhs
covet tracker where you can find out
just how your local trust is doing this
thing next to my head is a qr code if
you scan it on your phone it will take
you directly to the nhs tracker there
pop in a postcode and you'll find
relevant data including hospital
admissions the number of beds in use and
waiting times
a little later this morning had the
labour leader secure stammer giving a
speech in which he will set out his
plans to reform the nhs
you can watch that here live on sky news
just after 10
am he should be in the final stages of
preparation to defend his title in the
australian open which of course begins
on monday instead
novak djokovic is back in detention
awaiting a court hearing that will
decide if you'll be deported our
correspondent shingi maruriki has been
following the story morning again
is this it is this the final decision
will we finally work out whether or not
novak djokovic is getting kicked out of
australia or not
it looks like there'll be a decision but
if the decision goes the way of djokovic
the australian government can actually
still decide to revoke his visa for a
third time but as it stands tomorrow we
know that novak djokovic has an appeal
hearing after having his visa revoked
for a second time that takes place at 9
30 a.m tomorrow morning in australia
which is about 10 30 p.m tonight here
and this time the australian government
are using different grounds to revoke
his visa they are saying that because he
is a high-profile
unvaccinated individual he could foster
more anti-vac sentiment in australia
djokovic's lawyers tomorrow morning will
say that that is patently irrational and
that they are now using completely
different grounds to the first time that
they detained him for four days before
he was released on monday and of course
with all this legal to and fro happening
djokovic unlike his peers his rivals for
the australian open title is thinking
about legal proceedings while lots of
them are doing their last media duties
and their last preparations for the
tournament and time is running out he
was looking to become a 21-time grand
slam champion the most decorated male
tennis player of all time but there's a
very high chance that he may still
either have legal proceedings of hanging
over his head or he could be on a plane
back to serbia by monday evening rather
than taking to a tennis court
thank you
also making the news this morning uh
lawyers for virginia dufres the woman
accusing prince andrew of sexual assault
have requested permission to interview
two potential witnesses in the uk
one is a woman who allegedly saw the
duke of york in a nightclub with a young
girl
the other
a former assistant to the prince whose
name appeared in jeffrey epstein's black
book
meanwhile the 28th of june has been
announced as the sentencing date for
glenn maxwell the british socialite was
convicted last month on sex trafficking
charges relating to the recruitment of
teenage girls for the pedophile jeffrey
epstein
the actor alec baldwin has handed over
his mobile phone to investigators who
are looking into the fatal shooting of a
cinematographer on a film set last
october halner hutchins was killed when
a gun fired a live bullet during a
rehearsal for a scene in the western
film rust
coast guards around the uk will mark the
200th anniversary of the service today
founded in the year 1822 her majesty's
coast guard has
500 volunteers and 310 teams nationwide
to mark the milestone 200 throw lines
will be cast out around the country as a
symbol of the services dedication
a senior u.s official has told sky news
she believes russia is looking for an
excuse to invade ukraine and is warning
of widespread economic and political
consequences
but the under secretary of state says
she doesn't think a week of diplomatic
talks between russia and the west have
been entirely fruitless victoria newland
has been speaking to our u.s
correspondent mark stone
along europe's eastern flank the
soldiers of the ukrainian army are
digging in over the horizon russia's
military continues to mass a hundred
thousand soldiers and a week of
diplomacy has delivered nothing but
stalemate
now the americans say they believe
russia is looking for a reason to invade
and if they can't find one they'll
create one well this is straight out of
the russian playbook to try to
through sabotage operations through
false flag operations through
blaming the other guy
to create that pretext to give an excuse
to go in
or to make it look like the ukrainians
were the aggressors when in fact the
first aggression was perhaps even done
by russians against russians to blame
the ukrainians so it's all very
dangerous in the way they operate
under three presidencies victoria nuland
has had a focus on ukraine and russia
she is now under secretary of state just
put this moment in context for us how
serious is it how worried should are you
and how worried should we be
well mark it's extremely worrying you
know a nation does not deploy a hundred
thousand troops on the border of another
nation
and put its saboteurs inside the country
without some malign and aggressive
intent
russia insists that all this is part of
an exercise it has dismissed the false
flag accusations as nonsense its
diplomats say the aggressor is nato an
alliance advancing east that must be
counted
nato has no gripes with russia unless
russia is coming for us we've lived side
by side since the end of the cold war
some 30 years is america prepared to go
to war with russia
if it invades ukraine
what we are talking about here is
helping the ukrainians to defend
themselves
and preparing massive consequences
economic and political for moscow if it
walks away from the diplomatic table and
chooses aggression instead and we all
have to do that we can't allow countries
to change international borders by force
we'll have a free-for-all out there in
the world
but president putin already did that he
did that in crimea he did and
we know from history that sanctions
don't tend to work so you know
if they do invade what then that
question hasn't been answered what will
you
america do if russia goes ahead and
invades beyond sanctions what we're
preparing this time is far more severe
and painful for russia economically in
terms of its potential complete economic
isolation from the global financial
system as well as political isolation
the good news is that neither side has
ditched the diplomacy just yet talks
continue at many levels
and soldiers on both sides of the border
await orders mark stone sky news
but let's return to those fresh
developments in the case being brought
against prince andrew joining us now the
author nigel coughlin who brought prince
andrew epstein and the palace nigel
lovely to see you this morning um i i
wonder if we might just start with with
the events of course of of the past 24
48 hours um we know that he is a proud
man one wonders how he will be feeling
having been stripped of all those
military patronages
well
he's not just a proud man he i think
he's probably an angry man now that um
as the second in in uh the second sun
the spare as it were um you have very
little role in life
which were kind of uh
that that that gap was filled up with
all by with all these ceremonial
experimental roles that that
he has and and now has no more what else
has got to do apart from riley's
mother's horses around the winds of the
great park
well i mean it's an entertaining way to
spend an afternoon i'm sure
but in terms of of where he goes next i
mean it was the was there an
inevitability
to the decision which we presume was
taken at the very top
of the house of windsor to remove those
patronages to remove or or to stop him
from using the hrh title i mean was
there an inevitability that this was the
point we would have to end up in
well it was surprising it took so long
um because after all that um prince
harry was asked to to give up all his
military roles uh and stop using the hrh
title already and as far as i know he
hasn't been
[Music]
um uh
charged with any serious offense
so whether prince andrew then i mean
obviously his prime focus will be on uh
the virginia jeffrey case given uh that
the judge at first instance refused to
allow him to throw it out but
he he must have an eye on where he goes
after all of this finally concludes i
mean
this must be the end though of him as a
public figure
well in indeed so that that um
um
we must afford uh prince andrew like
anyone the uh presumption of innocence
however um he has kind of um
the monarchy by his very bad choice of
friends i mean he he was very close uh
friends and allies with with two
convicted sex
offenders now
which i think is kind of bad enough and
it as as it is without
um
seeing the judgment in this trial
yeah i mean we we can almost uh put
delane maxwell to one side in all of
this i mean as your book reveals you
know prince andrew was very well aware
of who jeffrey epstein was when he
returned to new york as we discovered uh
so that he could do the honorable thing
and say goodbye i mean did the reality
did the reality of what he was doing
during that trip to new york just not
register with the man
well plainly not i mean you don't go
and spend
four days living in someone's house just
to say
goodbye i'm not going to see you anymore
because
of what you've done um
you could have done that by a telephone
call or um an email
you didn't have to turn up a person
there and enjoy
the man's hospitality
i mean given all of that and look i
understand as well as anyone you know
the desire of a parent to look after
their child particularly the second
child but but
but
why was this allowed to continue
surely there was a point that prince
andrew should have departed public life
and it was long long ago
indeed it's very clear that that that
brent sandra is a man who
doesn't take advice
he was advised not to do that
disastrous um
news night interview which has really
sunk his ship
nigel cawthorn good to see you this
morning thanks for being with us okay my
pleasure
now it's usually the pursuit of
teenagers and baggy jeans but some
middle-aged people are now taking up
skateboarding at not me and a new study
has found that it can help to boost
happiness and well-being skies aisha's
ahead has been down to a skate park to
find out for herself
esther decided to give skateboarding to
go after everyday life began to feel too
stable five years later and now in her
early 50s it's a decision she hasn't
looked back on
i kind of had a couple of years of
feeling a bit purposeless in terms of
big life goals being completed and
being in a kind of professional
situation where one goes to work every
day and one comes home and i think
skateboarding just fitted in my life at
that time because it offered me
something else it offered me a new
challenge it offered me a chance to
learn again
there's a stereotype of the school board
is about freedom and it is about freedom
for me
but it's also about loads of other
things it's about pushing myself
challenging myself taking risks
building my strengths
emotionally and physically
esther isn't alone in taking up
skateboarding later in life
typically you'd expect to see this place
filled out with young people but more
and more older people are getting into
skateboarding experts say that the
activity can provide a real sense of
empowerment
at this skate park in south london
they've welcomed hundreds of new skaters
through their doors in the last year
with our monday night beginners nights
that was always just adults adults only
that was the only criteria
and that opened it up to a huge amount
of people so anyone from the ages of
18 to 50 could come as old as they want
and what we found is that
those people did start coming and they
started creating their own little
communities while it may not always feel
like the obvious choice for someone
older research suggests that
skateboarding not only improves mental
well-being but can also help people
navigate personal challenges
fundamentally you've got something
that's new engaging
gives you some exercise and can plug you
into a community
it doesn't solve all your problems
that's for sure but a lot of people find
that it's quite inspiring it's hoped
that getting on board could give many
more lycaster the boost they need aisha
zahid sky news
he created the office gave us extras and
now he's managing to make grief just a
little lighter
but for the third series ricky gervais
after life has resonated widely during
the pandemic skies claire gregory caught
up with the comedian along with some of
the cast to discuss just how the show
came together
i wish i'd teased her about there not
being an afterlife now i think she
wanted to believe in like heaven and
angels and stuff in the height of the
pandemic in spring 2020 grief was all
too close to home and ricky gervais's
story of a widower had audiences in
tears of sadness and laughter and went
on to become the most watched british
comedy program in the world the realer
someone is the better the performance um
the the more you more you laugh at the
jokes and the more you cry at the sad
bits
can i come over later i haven't even
finished and like with some of his
previous creations it's hard to know
where the character ends and your vase
begins
i think people have got this idea that
ricky's uh
quite arrogant yeah and a bit like david
brent yeah and he is he's exactly like
there is there is a touch there is a
touch
the main problem with ricky as a
director is that he just finds
everything funny so
like genuinely it can be a but i mean
there'd be scenes we've done in series
two when i was doing those things with
paul k he had to leave the room and be
listening to it on cans and we could
still hear him laughing outside the door
yeah i mean it was ridiculous i ruined
most takes yeah so that i mean that's
his that's your sort of uh your greatest
flaw i think as a director is that you
sabotage your own work
in the aftermath of the muted and scaled
back golden globes last week gervais's
scathing speeches as host in 2020 now
hold a special place in a ward's history
he's also the only person who ben
affleck hasn't been unfaithful to
please welcome matt damon
the first time i did it um 10 years ago
people going why is he saying awful
things these lovely these most important
people in the world and the world
changed and by the fifth time they were
going yeah go on give it to him we're
sick of them we're sick of celebrities
he's a baby
yeah but he's not the one making all the
noise is he you are yeah to keep him
amused because if he was crying that
would only people wouldn't do it no it
wouldn't because he's a baby for those
missing gervase's caustic wit this final
series will be welcome and will leave
many viewers wondering what's next for
him after after life claire gregory sky
news
[Music]
at time for the papers this morning in
the company of the anthropologist
marianna hotter and the journalist and
author pete price good to see you again
guys um pete to you first at the front
of the mail a story about zakir stama
and you have to forgive me a sense of
deja vu because i think i've seen this
story before somewhere
uh yeah the story came out i believe
last year uh but they're saying pot
cattle black and they're also saying um
should the labor leader um demand his
own resignation do you know what upsets
me about this is i think we've only just
started on this one i think we're gonna
have even more mps and and political
leaders from other parties are gonna be
exposed because i just find it unreal
that somebody's gone past and taken a
photograph through the window apparently
there's about five people there and some
of them are eating as well but the labor
said the labour party have said they
haven't broken any laws at all but it
did come out last year this picture um
and i just wonder how many mps have not
uh broken the law and do we have
everyone resigning because of drinking
because we'll have no governments left
uh or waiting governments um i i've been
expecting this photo to come out again
i'm surprised at it but i really who
invented phones on telephones uh sorry
um cameras on telephones what is that
all about it's just you can't go
anywhere do anything so this is i think
the start of what's gonna happen on the
comeback to the labor against
conservatives
mp i think you're going to have an awful
couple of years if you've only just
discovered about camera phones honestly
they're everywhere these days um but
marianne take his take tickets then take
swiss you might want to reflect on on
the kind of the the contrast between
sarkir starmer he's not apologizing for
this they say it was a a work event on
the front of the express where we
understand that that downing street has
apologized to buckingham palace although
we are still in a little bit of doubt as
to what exactly it was they're
apologizing for
yeah so i mean the thing is pete i think
if
that photograph is the worst that the
male can find about the the leader of
the opposition or the opposition party
uh mp's sort of misbehavior that he's
got a beer in his hand while other
people are having dinner and there are
five other people in the room i do
wonder whether that possibly suggests
and i'm not a member of the labour party
i'm not um you know sort of lobbying on
their behalf but i do wonder whether
that suggests that perhaps they had a
culture where they were attempting at
least to follow the rules a little more
carefully than
the mighty leaders of our country and
the government um who have now got a
lead civil service to grey investigating
13 alleged parties and of course this
unprecedented apology to buckingham
palace from downing street not from the
prime minister personally but from
number 10 downing street
because
two of the parties were held the evening
before prince philip's funeral so this
is a period of national mourning this is
just hours before we saw our monarch a
queen in her 90s
sitting alone in saint george's chapel
burying her husband on her own and
obviously
that's the queen it's such a visible
physical visceral symbol of what
everybody has had to give up even the
queen
and that story that story of tragedy and
isolation and loss and loneliness and
struggle is something that
many many millions of people around this
country have shared people have
harrowing stories of what they have lost
because of sacrifices they've made to
keep everybody more safe from covid and
i think the things that we have to look
at now is
not just how many more allegations are
going to come out how many more
revelations about
the kind of scandalous things that
people were getting up to because the
rules didn't apply to them
um i think we have to start looking at
what needs to happen now
and
boris johnson's line has been
consistently we need to wait for the
outcome of sue gray's investigation that
is very hotly anticipated in the in the
coming days hopefully this week
well could be to be fair she's she has
it she has got an awful lot on her plate
now and i mean it does
this yeah but we can't wait too long
because otherwise it becomes old news
everyone attempts to shrug it off and
say oh well you know
it happened a long time ago we've got
you know more important things to worry
about russia is about to invade ukraine
all the rest of it but this really
matters because this is about
our leaders lying to us and pete take us
inside the times and a story that i
think will will resonate with some
people in particular because of that
that meeting between the health
secretary and an unvaccinated
anaesthetist that took place just just a
few days ago but perhaps as much as what
10 percent of staff
could be on their way to the uh to the
exit
yeah i saw the uh story on sky and i was
visibly shocked uh we could lose 10
percent of of the health staff they have
to have a job by the third of february
uh to have the second job by april when
they could uh lose their jobs
i really
don't understand and i know some people
medically can't have
the vaccination but i really don't
understand
what is going on uh i know a lot of
people in the medical profession they
shake their heads in disbelief at the
anti-vaxxers within um the nhs we've got
enough problems with people who are
stressed who are work to death and now
we could lose 10
within the nhs that really is a very
frightening situation but i i really
don't understand when this talk about
the antibodies when they i mean if
millions upon millions upon millions of
people around the world have all had
their jobs and it seems to be helping us
enormously why can't the nhs staff um
have the jab i really can't get my head
around this at all but it's frightening
for the staff that are left and in the
care workers as well i don't know what
the answer is but it frightens the life
out of me and when i saw that interview
on sky
i stood back in disbelief yeah and all
at a time of course of of unprecedented
sick leave because of covid um marianne
let's go to the front of the telegraph
and
it's an interesting picture tell us why
we're focusing on princess princess
beatrice today
yeah so this is the revelation that the
duke of york he is no longer prince
andrew he can't be um his royal highness
all those titles have been stripped by
the queen and brought back to um they're
going to be kind of given to other
members of the royal family he's um
going to be facing a civil trial by jury
in new york because of the allegations
that he had sex with a 17 year old um
multiple occasions and so
the the revelation i guess is that um
his daughter beatrice is probably going
to be embroiled in this if it does go to
tri um if it does go to trial because
she'll be called as a witness um not
just to corroborate
the um alibi that he's provided
previously which was that he was having
dinner with her in a pizza express in
woking rather than having sex with an
underage girl uh one evening
and um that he can't sweat and therefore
the allegation that he was a a sweaty
person um or he couldn't sweat at the
time
i don't know if that still continues to
be the case for him uh allegedly um
whether his daughter would have insight
into that or not so it is it besmirches
the monarchy of course um and it's
important that we establish the truth it
might not go to trial
there is the uh possibility that there
would be a settlement out of court that
would probably be financial but also may
well involve some kind of public apology
or um
acceptance or statement that there was
wrong doing now did you feel that median
i will believe that when i see it
frankly
he's denied all the charges so
it's um it's it's a horrible horrible
situation for a 33 year old for a you
know young woman to be asked to to kind
of go into public to
defend or or you know denounce her
father that's pretty grim and pete's
this story to round off there i have to
say is a cracker tell us about the poor
chat who thought his numbers were in but
instead his numbers up
14 million he thought he'd won he's
going to buy his mother a house and
himself a ferrari he put the numbers on
on the wrong day how do you get it mixed
up i'll never know in a million years
but he got the the whole thing was
completely wrong the euro millions and
he just got the wrong table oh i mean
he's the the unluckiest lad in britain
he's the most unluckiest man in the
world how do you live with yourself
you'll have to go and join bonus for a
drink cheer himself up
or just pop right into yours and just
dip you know just go underneath that in
that drinks trolley there will you stop
going on about my drinks trolley now
we're gonna fall out
i just and on that bombshell pete
marianne we will see what we'll at least
see you at next our mary and i'm not so
sure about pete at the moment we'll see
you next time i hope fingers crossed
it's still to come on breakfast
appropriately enough we'll be discussing
wine time fridays uh full details of the
latest allegations of lockdown breaking
drinking sessions at number 10.
[Music]
you